le traité de Lisée a été signé en
janvier 63 un traité pour céder les
liens entre la France et l'Allemagne et
fixé des objectifs de coopération 50 ans
plus tard le sujet en pleine crise
européenne et plus que d'actualité d'où
ces premières rencontres franco-allemand
qui se sont déroulés ce mercredi à
Versailles à tout prix avoir un
événement en Île-de-France ce n'est pas
le cas il y a eu un événement à sabrück
qui a eu un événement extraire de Reims
il y en aura à la semaine prochaine à
luzzisburg qui est où le général de
Gaulle a fait son discours à la jeunesse
allemande en allemand en 62 et il nous
fallait un événement sur Paris et
Versailles s'y prêtait parfaitement bien
Versailles est une île chargée
d'histoire dans la relation
franco-allemande et vous avez un aspect
historique dramatique on le sait bien
sûr
119 le traité de Versailles où les
Allemands finalement sont acculés à
cette capitulation
des experts du monde économique
universitaires étaient présents pour
échanger autour d'un invité d'honneur
Alain Juppé l'ancien ministre des
Affaires étrangères trouve une
signification toute politique à ses
rencontres la relation franco-allemande
est plus que jamais une responsabilité
historique dans une Europe dont on voit
bien aujourd'hui les turbulences de ces
échanges doivent déboucher de nouveaux
projets de coopération qui seront
présentés au président français et à la
chancelière allemande un colloque
surtout ouvert aux plus jeunes cela
n'est pas anodin le département compte
un établissement franco-allemand à Buc
et un lycée international à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye